-Hey, everybody.
Thank you so much for tuning in.
Thanks for watching
"The Tonight Show."
My name's Jimmy Fallon, and that
is the Roots right over there,
ladies and gentlemen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's get to the news and jokes.
Well, guys, the big story
is still the Supreme Court,
and today it looks like
the Republicans cleared
an important hurdle.
-Senator Lindsey Graham,
the chair of
the Senate Judiciary Committee,
now says the Republicans
have the votes to confirm
President Trump's nominee to
fill Justice Ginsburg's seat
before the election, before they
even know who the nominee is.
-That's right.
51 out of 53 Republicans
are now on board
while the other two stick out
like masks at a MAGA rally.
[ Laughter ]
That's right. The Republicans
are really backing Trump
on this.
They were like,
"We got him through Mueller,
the impeachment,
and that time he called America
'the United Schess.'
We're not stopping now."
[ Laughter ]
Now it sounds like a vote could
be held in just a few weeks.
Man, we haven't seen Republicans
move this fast
since Men's Warehouse
had a closing sale.
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, you can tell
Senate Republicans
are loving life right now.
They haven't been this happy
since "Blue Bloods"
started streaming on Hulu.
[ Laughter ]
It's pretty wild.
The Republicans are
in favor of Trump's nominee,
and he hasn't named one yet.
Even the people who got engaged
on "Love Is Blind" were like,
"Don't you want to see
who it is first?"
How do you agree to put someone
on the Supreme Court
before you know who they are?
I don't even pick up
a phone call
when I don't know who it is.
Unknown? I know like
four of those people.
[ Laughter ]
I'm not gonna pick up right now.
I still can't believe we're
letting Trump make that choice.
He's terrible at hiring people.
Everyone he's ever hired
is either fired, in prison,
or in Steve Bannon's case,
almost both.
[ Laughter ]
Well, guys, last night in Ohio
Trump held another rally,
and he said something
pretty interesting
about who the coronavirus
affects.
Watch this.
-We now know the disease.
We didn't know it.
Now we know it.
It affects elderly people,
elderly people with heart
problems and other problems.
Nobody young.
Below the age of 18,
like nobody.
But it affects virtually nobody.
It's an amazing thing.
-Well, I think he's officially
done up-playing the virus.
[ Laughter ]
Trump said the virus affects
"virtually nobody."
Then somebody
in the front row sneezed,
and Trump hit the floor
like he dropped his remote.
[ Laughter ]
After Trump made that comment,
doctors and nurses
wanted to respond,
but they're currently in the
middle of a 4,000-hour shift.
Affects virtually nobody?
How could he say that?
Right now my entire staff
is dressed like
a bunch of welders
who went scuba diving.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, as COVID cases begin
to rise again in the U.K.,
Prime Minister Boris Johnson
has decided to take action.
-We are once again
asking office workers
who can work from home to do so.
Unless we palpably make
progress, we should assume that
the restrictions I've announced
will remain in place
for perhaps six months.
-Yeah, people immediately
promised to follow the rules
because if they don't,
Boris Johnson threatened
to send them to America.
[ Laughter ]
Can we see Boris Johnson again?
Yeah. It's not good when
Americans look at him and say,
"I wish we had
someone like that."
[ Laughter ]
Well, listen to this.
I read that Walmart is
going to start delivering
COVID-19 test kits by drone.
Yep. The good news -- there's
a new COVID drone from Walmart.
The bad news --
it's being operated by
an 85-year-old greeter.
"Hold still.
Here comes the airplane."
[ Laughter ]
I'm no expert,
but if you told me 20 years ago
we'd have flying drones
delivering pandemic test kits
to our house, I'd say things
did not go well.
[ Laughter ]
Some sports news.
On Sunday, a few NFL coaches
didn't wear masks
on the sidelines.
And now they're being punished
by the league.
Check it out.
-The NFL has dished out
more than $1 million in fines
for coaches not wearing masks
on the sidelines on Sunday.
Three head coaches --
Seattle's Pete Carroll,
Denver's Vic Fangio,
and San Francisco's
Kyle Shanahan
each fined $100,000.
-$100,000.
Even for them,
that's a lot of money.
To put that into perspective,
punching a ref is
just 50 bucks and an apology.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, over $1 million
in fines or,
as Trump put it,
"virtually nothing."
Yep, they want the coaches
wearing masks.
Meanwhile, the maskless players
all ran back
to the ventless locker room
and showered together.
[ Laughter ]
Well, this isn't good.
After launching
less than six months ago,
the streaming platform Quibi is
now exploring a potential sale.
Quibi actually announced they
were for sale a few months ago,
but no one saw it.
[ Laughter ]
Quibi failed when everyone
was home doing nothing.
That's like offering water
at the end of a marathon
and every runner is like,
"Nah, I'm good."
[ Laughter ]
"I'm just extremely thirsty
is all."
Actually, I like Quibi
because it's the only thing
in 2020 that seemed to go fast.
And finally,
this is a strange anniversary.
60 years ago today
President Nixon ate
half a sandwich in Illinois.
Listen to what happened
to the other half.
-I picked it up and hopped on
my bicycle and sped home.
I said,
"Mom, I've got the sandwich
that Nixon took a couple bites
out of."
I stuck it in the freezer,
and that's the way it still is
today, 60 years later.
[ Laughter ]
-And 60 years from now,
his grandkid will show off
Trump's half-eaten Big Mac.
[ Laughter ]
I'm just kidding.
He didn't leave half.